good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm doing
a photo shoot in which they want me to
pretend to vlog so I'm going to actually
vlog here all the people taking my
picture well cope in Los Angeles at 6:15
in the morning on Saturday brush my
teeth got my picture taken while taking
moving pictures of myself and then got
on a hotel elevator clearly not designed
for people who fear Heights at all met
up with Eleanor & Park by Rainbow Rowell
and went to USC for the LA Times Book
Festival where my longtime editor Julie
Strauss gable was talking to my event
wegen and a 15 year old who has written
a fascinating and wonderful
anthropological experiment slash memoir
called popular that I got to ride in a
golf cart you can just see my glee
before heading backstage to prepare for
my event I was very nervous backstage
but man the lighting was fantastic hey
before I go on stage for book stuff now
I always remind myself of my readings
and there were many of them that were
attended by between 0 and 3 people and I
give thanks for Brotherhood 2.0 and
nerdfighteria and for you Hank and then
I take a deep breath and well so I talk
to all these nice people for a while and
then went over to sign books for several
hours where I met lots of people with
various okayokay shirts and tiffy OS
iPhone cases and tiffy O's nails and a
dog named Alaska and this couple who met
through nerdfighteria and now are
married then I met up with my friend
Veronica Roth and shortly thereafter
fell asleep in the cab on the way back
to the hotel I was trying to film myself
fake falling asleep but then I actually
fell asleep so it goes woke up the next
morning at 5:15 to watch a Liverpool
Manchester City which was wonderful and
then terrifying and then wonderful again
yes we did it Hank
we being of course the people on the
pitch the people in the stadium and me
in Los Angeles wearing my Liverpool
jacket then I got to see my friend T
Cooper who wrote changers and then I had
to do a different hotel to meet oh look
it's Ansel Elgort who plays Gus in The
Fault in Our Stars and whose worldview
involves a great deal of shirtlessness
and frankly who among us can blame him
Sarah was there too and we drank
champagne by the pool which was awesome
and then we got all fancy for the MTV
Movie Awards met up with NAT Wolff and
soon found ourselves on an actual red
carpet Hank I really love nerdfighteria
and the chance to talk about stuff I
care about with people I care about but
I don't particularly want to be like a
real celebrity which is why we've always
turned on TV stuff but I'm really proud
of the tidiest movie and I want to
support it and plus I like hanging out
with NAT so there we were on the very
same red carpet as like Jonah Hill and
grumpy cat not and I attempted to answer
questions even though the screaming and
the cameras resulted in both of us to
use Internet parlance losing our ability
to even it was really really
overwhelming Hank and interviewers kept
asking me how I was handling the
attention that accompanies a book
becoming a movie and different community
would change because of it and I wanted
to answer every question by saying I am
freaking out right now
and I found myself thinking of grumpy
cat who in spite of it all remained you
know cat-like and grumpy and I thought
you know what
grumpy cat has this thing figured out so
nerdfighteria this is gonna be weird and
hopefully awesome but let's just focus
on continuing to do the stuff that were
good at okay and on that subject I hang
me from the future here in a stunning
turn of events I find myself in an
airport anyway we are relaunching the
nerdfighter book club and our new book
is gonna be behind the beautiful
forevers by Katherine boo a fascinating
and nuanced to look at poverty and one
indian community so check it out links
in the doobly-doo